good evening and welcome to the lens ik
I'm Chris campus I'm a professor of the
Santa Fe Institute where I research
general laws in biology with the hope of
being able to predict things like
evolutionary history and astrobiology
the San Fay Institute has been hosting
these community lectures since 1986 and
this series has produced lively and
diverse talks on a variety of
cutting-edge research topics for 33
years now in addition to being very
interesting the series serves as a
reflection of the diverse set of
research activities ongoing at the
Institute activities that span the
sciences and find commonality between
diverse ideas over the years SFI has
brought thought leaders at the forefront
of science to the Santa Fe Institute and
to Santa Fe for these lectures and past
lecturers have included
Francis Crick Kenneth arrow and Leonard
Susskind amongst many many others the
Santa Fe Institute has been able to
produce these high-quality lectures
thanks to partnerships with our
community minded local organizations and
with that I'd like to give a special
thank you to Thornburg investment
management who has generously
underwritten this lecture series for the
last five years without their support we
would not be able to host these lectures
at all let alone continue to offer them
to Santa Fe at no cost so let's think
Thornburg
we'd also like to thank the lensing
Performing Arts Center for their
additional support of this series and
lastly we'd like to extend our thanks to
a new supporter the Santa Fe reporter
for tonight we are lucky enough to have
Danielle Bassett giving our lecture
Danielle is a professor at the
University of Pennsylvania where she
works on an enormous range of topics
Danny's work spans condensed matter
physics to neuroscience to social
systems and in each of these areas she
brings new theoretical and mathematical
tools to bear an important pure and
applied problems the questions that she
is interested in are some of the most
interesting and modern science what are
human algorithm an algorithm for
learning how can interventions be taken
on the dynamics of a brain how do we
encode curiosity Danny will talk much
more about these topics tonight and I
just want to mention that she has a very
long list of accolades which I couldn't
possibly list here tonight so if I sit
suffice to say that she these include
winning a MacArthur Fellowship and
Alfred P Sloan fellowship and the air
dish ready prize in network science I'm
very much looking forward to her talk
and with that please help me in
welcoming Danielle Bassett thank you
very much I'm very excited to be here
tonight thank you for the organizers and
the donors who made this possible it's a
really wonderful set of events and I'm
excited to be a part of it
and most of all I'm very excited to meet
all of you I think this is probably the
first time we've met at least for most
of us I often get a little bit nervous
the first time I meet someone so I've
read somewhere in a book that one a
really great thing to do if you're
nervous meeting someone for the first
time is to tell them a little bit about
yourself
so I've decided to tell you a little bit
about my
so I was home-schooled from kindergarten
through 12th grade so all the way
through until I went to college and my
parents had this really wonderful home
library that was had at least a thousand
books the last time we counted and so I
I grew up really loving reading and
loving all kinds of areas of science of
humanities of philosophy and in fact
when I became around high school-aged I
really thought that I was going to be a
philosopher um so there's that and then
another interesting tidbit about myself
is that my dad is an orthopedic surgeon
and when I was young even sort of seven
years old he would come back with videos
of new surgeries they had to learn and
he would play them on the local video
you know our videotape just I forget
what they used to call them but anyway
and I would I would sit there next to
him and watch these videos of these new
different kinds of surgeries that he had
to do so I became really fascinated by
the human body and by the the beautiful
mechanics of the human body and the idea
that a physician can intervene so
carefully and so precisely to make
someone better so I became very
interested in biology at that point as
well and then lastly it towards the
later years of high school while
homeschooled high school I became very
interested in mathematics and in physics
and I just thought it was so amazing
that we could take these very simple
formalisms and formulations and use them
to understand the world around us I was
just blown away by the fact that we can
use these these simple mathematical
constructs to explain really complicated
things from the universe to the human
mind so one thing I think that was a
common theme across all of these
different interests was the mind so
whether it was philosophy of the mind
biology of the minds or mathematics of
the mind and ever since then I've been
really fascinated with the mind itself
I'm trying to tackle it from all of
these different perspectives so when I
think about the mind today is a little
bit different than how I thought about
it as a seven-year-old when I think
about the mind today I often actually
think about Leonardo da Vinci and the
reason that I think about him is that he
may
some of the most beautiful artistic
representations of the organ of the mind
which is the human brain and when I
think about Leonardo da Vinci I often
think about his book called thoughts on
art and life and the reason that I think
about that book is that it it provides a
really beautiful context for why the
mind does what it does often it's to
create or to engage in relationships
with other individuals and that brings
me to thinking about love and friendship
which motivates many of the things that
we do in our lives whether it's science
or art and when I begin to think about
love and friendship I think about
Facebook and Twitter and snapchat and
obviously Leonardo da Vinci is Feli
rolling over in his grave that I put
these two on the same slide so I
apologize but I do want to ask the
question is this more than just free
association what do these two things
have in common if anything on the left
hand side we have social engineering
systems like Facebook I actually didn't
even know the little icon for snapchat I
had to put that in somebody told me I
should really you know get with the
program alright so what is what is a
similarity between a social engineering
program and our the human brain on the
surface of it these two things are could
not be more different however if you
think about them in terms of their
underlying mathematical structure they
have some really beautiful similarities
that we can actually use to try to
understand the human brain better and
that underlying mathematical similarity
is that they both turn out to be
networks so what is a network a network
is an object like this which is composed
of units which we often called nodes and
then relationship between units which we
often call edges now the first very
simple question is how is Facebook or
other social engineering systems a
network and that's pretty
straightforward right so a node in the
network is a person and a edge between
two people is a friendship and of course
we can put terms on here like the geeks
and the jocks and the emo and the goth
which were very relevant when I was
younger I've been told by undergraduates
who engage in research in my laboratory
that these terms are very outdated
so you can put whichever term you prefer
from your experience high school
experience probably on those little
groupings okay
so the mapping of friendships to
networks is very straightforward but
what about the brain how is the brain a
network on the surface of it this is a
wet gooey organ that sits inside of your
skull and there's nothing about it that
is really particulate in that way that a
social network is so what I'd like to do
is to suggest that we look inside and
see whether we can understand
mathematically why the network structure
is relevant for understanding the mind
the first question we have to ask is
what are the nodes in this network what
are the pieces what are the units of the
human mind and that's obviously a
question that's been asked not just
today but in historical times as well
and was answered in a in the
pseudoscience of phrenology so at that
point the idea was that there are
specific portions of the brain that code
for specific functions or even specific
morphologies of the skull that code for
specific functions as well and so in the
age of phrenology we would have regions
that are important for ideology for
veneration for firmness for benevolence
and for human nature itself so very very
abstract concepts
now the actual terms that are located
here and associated to specific regions
of the brain are not the way that we
think about it as neuro scientists today
however the idea that a region can code
for a single function is something that
we do hold as neuro scientists and why
did we hold that what experimental
evidence has been brought to bear to
suggest that we often use what's called
a magnetic resonance imaging machine and
these are commonly found in hospitals
and research grade ones are often found
either at research hospitals or at
universities and what these machines do
is that they allow us to map out the
regions that have become active in the
brain when we perform a particular task
so if you read the New York Times or
Scientific American or Discover Magazine
you probably often see pictures like
what you see on the bottom right which
is a brain with some color on it usually
yellows and reds that indicate that's
the region that becomes active when you
do
X in this case it's playing the piano
your motor cortex becomes active now
what's nice about this is that we can go
through and have human volunteers
perform many different tasks inside of
the scanner and then we can identify oh
that's the region that becomes active
when you speak that's the region that
becomes active when you do this that's
the region that becomes active when you
do that and that helps us to map out
what these nodes are what these regions
are that code for specific functions but
that's not the end of the story where
are the edges inside of this system now
understanding the edges or the
relationships or connections between
different parts of the brain is an
endeavor that has also been important
over several decades and probably the
most canonical circuit that we know of
is the circuit involved in language
processing and so when you think about
language you have to realize that
there's actually no single piece of your
brain that becomes active in language
processing or in language production
it's actually a whole set of regions so
information comes in through your visual
cortex if you're reading or through your
auditory cortex if you're listening as
you are doing right now and then it gets
propagated through the rest of the brain
to Broca's area and Wernicke's area and
then eventually out into motor cortex
which allows you to speak back to me or
to raise your hand or to do the other
motoric movements that you that you do
in response to speech so in other words
there's a whole constellation of regions
and their relationships the passage of
information between them that allows you
to perform language now that's really
nice if we're talking about language
however there are many functions of a
human brain that we do not understand at
that level we don't understand what the
circuits actually are and so often we're
faced with a question of how could we
perhaps find all circuits that are
available to the brain to use and
answering that question has actually
only become possible in the last roughly
10 years and that is through this
specific type of imaging which is called
diffusion imaging this is again Donna on
a magnetic resonance imaging machine but
it maps out the diffusion of water
molecules inside of your brain now water
molecules if you didn't know are
constantly bouncing around in your brain
by Brownian
but they are actually constrained along
these big bundles of neuronal axons so
for anybody who sort of forgets or has
not learned what a neuronal axon is
neurons are cell bodies in the brain and
the neuron cell body looks a little bit
like a hand has a center and then it has
dendrites coming out of it then it has a
long tail that long tail is called an
axon and that allows that cell to
communicate to the other cell that's way
down here okay so what you have in your
brain is huge bundles of these axons
that allow for information to be passed
form from one piece of the brain to
another and that's those streamlines are
those threads that you see in the brain
right there now what's fascinating about
this sort of picture is that it can be
acquired non-invasively in any human so
meaning it doesn't hurt you there's no
side effects it's just an image like an
x-ray for example and what's also
fascinating about this is that these
patterns this the connections inside of
your brain are different for every
single person and what scientists are
finding over the last couple years is
that that pattern is almost like a
fingerprint and it relates to many of
the things or helps us understand many
of the things that you find easy to do
in your daily life and also many of the
things that you find more difficult and
we'll get to that in a second all right
so those are the edges inside of the
network so here is the network now right
so there are nodes which are regions of
the brain that code for a specific
function and then there then there are
these wires that connect up different
parts of the brain alright so now we
have a network now we understand why
it's like Facebook right but now the
question is how do we study it and how
do we use that information to try to
understand how the brain truly works
what we often use are many tools that
have been developed in the field of
network science which is a very
interdisciplinary and rather emerging
area of science that allows us to think
about complex systems by distilling them
down into their units and a pattern of
relationships between their units the
field pulls on many other traditionally
distinct disciplines like computer
science mathematics physics engineering
statistics and even visualization
actually so what we do is that we use
these kind of tools to be understand
the architecture of a network is now if
I show you these two networks let's say
one of them is my brain and one of them
is my friend's brain and I asked you are
these two networks the same or different
actually I could ask my preschooler that
and he would say of course they're
different but then if I ask well how are
they different can you tell me how
they're different that becomes a lot
harder this is they're both pretty
complicated patterns so what network
science does is that allows us to use
mathematics to explicitly quantify
what's different about the pattern on
the left from the pattern on the right
and why that becomes important is that
then we can compare a healthy brain with
one that has a disease or we can compare
an eight-year-old brain with a 22 year
old brain and these comparisons become
important for us to understand cognitive
function alright so in truth Network
science is basically a bunch of math
that allows us to characterize the
architecture of these systems now I want
you to give you an intuition for why
this matters and how it works I want to
understand the brain okay so here is the
most fantastic information processing
system you can imagine not actually it's
a very simple toy graph but what I want
you to imagine is that we want to use
this to transfer information now if I
wanted to start and have information law
on this left side over here and I wanted
to send information all the way over to
the other side I have a couple options
of how I would want to do that perhaps
and the smartest way to do it would be
to follow these red lines so I take one
hop two hops three hops right so I can
get information from one side of the
network to the other side in three hops
or I could take a more circuitous route
so for perhaps I could go down around
here and then around here and
around here a couple times maybe you
know and then eventually over here
that's what your your mind feels like on
a red-eye you know it's like well taking
you a few extra turns around the corner
there all right so what we can do is
that we can actually quantify that idea
by calculating what's called the
shortest path from one piece in the
network to another so the shortest path
here is through one two three hops and
obviously there are many longer paths
but we care about the shorter paths and
the question is how would you construct
a brain network if you had the option of
constructing one so that it had
relatively short paths to get from any
piece of the brain to any other piece of
the brain your brain is an amazing
information processing machine that has
to be able to transmit information very
freely across across wide ranges of
space all right
so we could build a network like this
which is where we have a lot of local
connectivity however this is not
particularly good for information
transmission right because if I had to
send information from the left side to
the right side I'd have to go across
half of the circle okay not so efficient
on the right hand side this is a
relatively efficient information
transmission system because it can send
information from one side to the other
very quickly however it loses the
capacity to have local information
processing so there's no help by
neighboring regions to process
information this middle piece right here
has the best of both worlds which is
that you have local processing here as
well as these short these long-distance
connections that allow you to transmit
information to the other side very very
quickly so when we look at humans we
actually find that many that all of us
have this sort of architecture and in
fact it's not just humans then we also
see that across many different species
so we've studied humans we've studied
macaque monkeys we have studied mice
Drosophila which is a fly and the
elegans which is a nematode or worm and
what we found is that very very
consistently there tend to be mostly
local paths but then these short these
long-distance connections which allow
short cuts of information transmission
across the entire brain and that's very
consistent across all the species but
then if we just or that we've studied
this
that we've studied I should say but then
if we just look inside of the human and
we look at the variation in this feature
across humans we can actually see that
that variation is related to the way
that brain works so this is a really
beautiful study not from my lab but from
another lab that shows that this
prevalence of short paths in the network
is actually positively related to full
scale IQ so individuals who have higher
IQ tend to have relatively short paths
through their brain networks and
individuals with lower IQ tend to have
longer paths within their brain networks
and that's really interesting because it
suggests that this network
representation of a human brain is not
only an interesting correspondence to
social networks but it's relevant for
understanding how the system works as an
information processing system okay now
why do you think short paths would make
for better brains this so this is a
simulation where we're just trying to
illustrate the fact that if you want to
transmit information across this entire
system you have to have on average
relatively short paths throughout the
entire thing but I also hope that this
movie makes you start thinking about not
just where the paths are but how
information gets transmitted and so I
want to make it I want to make an
analogy to traffic and to roadway
systems because I think it's helpful to
help us understand how the brain works
so on the left-hand side these
structural wires that I told you about
earlier I think of them as sort of the
highways of the brain but knowing where
the highways are is not as important at
least to me living around Philadelphia
as knowing what the traffic is like on
each of the highways right I really want
to know what the traffic is so that I
can choose the correct path for myself
to get to Penn in time for my class all
right so we want to make the just we
want to distinguish between the
structural highways and the traffic that
exists on top of them now what I would
really love to do and say to you tonight
is that we have a perfect measurement of
traffic on human brains that's
non-invasive the answer is we actually
don't have that however what we can do
is make an indirect inference of where
the traffic is in
brain and the way that we do that is
that we say well let's measure the
activity of every single brain region in
this second and let's measure it again
at this second and let's measure it
again at this second and every second
we'll take a picture of the pattern of
activity across the entire brain and
then what we'll do is that will say if
two regions of the brain are changing in
activity with one another then there
possibly sharing information with each
other so in other words if two regions
are increasing in activity together and
then decreasing in activity together and
then increasing again together and
decreasing again together so they're
following each other in their activity
we say that those two regions are
functionally connected they're probably
responding to the same stimulus or
possibly sharing information among them
so that's our measurement of traffic for
a human brain and it's a non-invasive
measurement so then once we do that we
can construct a second type of Network
for the human which is the traffic
network we call it a functional Network
and an interesting question is how
should I study that network to better
understand how cognitive processes
function in a healthy human or in a non
healthy human and I actually want to go
back to the illustration from social
networks because I think it actually
helps us very much to understand what to
do here so here's an example of a social
network that I want to draw on so this
is a picture of Caltech Facebook friends
and so each dot here is a different
student at Caltech the color of the dot
indicates the house that the student
lived in and so what you can generally
see is a strong clustered structure or
we often call it community structure or
modular structure and you often find
that over here most of the people who
live in the yellow house tend to be
friends with other people in the yellow
house that makes sense people in the
purple house here tend to also be
friends with other people in the purple
house there are these really interesting
people in the center that don't tend to
be friends with their own house but tend
to be friends with at least one other
person in almost every house so those
are really fascinating because they can
be important brokers of information
between the different houses and that
actually becomes very important when we
think about the brain as well because
there
these areas in the brain as well that
sit between different clusters the other
important feature I wanted to point out
over here is that there's a little red
guy right inside of the purple house so
he's not friends with anyone in the red
house but he's friends with everyone in
the purple house and we're pretty sure
he should move so here is the picture of
what that sort of structure looks like
in a human brain so here each of the the
circles is a region of the brain and the
color code from the left hand side is
the same as the color code on the right
so you can map across so for example
these regions over here are very
strongly connected with one another
they're all located in the back of your
brain which is the occipital cortex that
helps you with visual processing or
processing information that comes in
through your eyes there are also regions
of the brain over here in purple that
are important for audition so listening
and also for a language and there are
regions of the brain that are important
for many other functions as well what we
basically find is that there are these
separate groups that seem to performing
perform specific kinds of functions and
that's shown by their pattern of
activity they're dynamic pattern of
activity and I like to liken this to an
orchestra where we have many different
kinds of functions in an orchestra right
we have the brass we have the strings we
have the woodwinds we have the
percussion and they tend frequently to
be communicating with one another in the
sense that they're playing similar
melodies specifically the strings but
that's also true for some of the other
systems as well so we have that
separation and yet together it creates
this resonant beautiful architecture
which is what we see in the human mind
as well okay so this observation that
there are a really beautiful clustered
structure inside of the brain and that
those clusters seem to code for specific
kinds of functions is something that's
motivated many new questions across a
wide variety of areas so I wanted to
specifically highlight these because it
helps to showcase the interdisciplinary
nature of the investigations that are
going on motivated by this work so
number one in psychology we ask how do
these networked modules change in
different brain States number two in
neuroscience what
rolls do neurophysiological processes
play in the in these modules number
three in medicine how our networks
altered in psychiatric disease or in
neurological disorders in mathematics we
try to understand what graph models are
most like the brain and why in
statistics we're trying to understand
how we can infer true signal from noise
in the data in physics we're trying to
understand what role that network
structure plays and material properties
that's actually extremely important for
traumatic brain injury so if you have
this structural wiring in your brain
right that's that's very heterogeneous
that actually is a conduit for force
from a traumatic brain injury in a way
that differs across depending on where
the individual was hit and so that's
this work is playing a very important
role in understanding the effect of
traumatic brain injury on cognition and
then in art what role does the network
structure play in the creative process
and why so I think that all of these
questions are very exciting and I could
certainly finish off the talk with these
questions but I actually want to place
the statement out there that there's one
big elephant in the room from all of
this work and that is that if I really
want to understand human cognition
there is no single picture I could show
you that would explain human cognition
and that's because a picture ignores the
dimension of time human cognition is
dynamic it's changing constantly right
so if we want to understand how the
human mind works we have to have an
approach that's dynamic in nature how
are these networks changing as you think
about going home tonight or as you go to
work tomorrow how did they change over
development how do they change with age
how do they change when you're anxious
versus less anxious so this is really
where the work needs to go so how can we
do that well one way is that we can take
those same images of the brain and those
same patterns of activity that we
acquire from magnetic resonance imaging
and we can say well let's extract the
functional Network so that traffic
network just from the first two min
of data okay and then let's look at the
next two minutes of data and construct a
network of what paths were used there
and then the next two minutes of data
and the next two minutes of data that
allows us to actually create an avi of
the network reconfiguring over time
showing different powers of information
processing and communication as a
function of time so where have we been
using that we've been using that
technique to understand long term
reconfigurations and human learning and
we've been focusing initially on motor
skill learning and so that's relevant
for a child learning to ride a tricycle
is relevant for anyone who plays a
musical musical instrument that's motor
learning it's also relevant for anyone
who plays a sport that's also motor
learning so how does this happen
how does motor learning happen in the
brain and can we watch it happen in real
time and see how these networks are
changing the way that we did that Alysha
lee in the lab is through a very highly
stylized experiment which i've been told
is very similar to guitar hero for
anybody who has played guitar hero
before so the idea is basically that
human participants volunteers go into
the scanner and they see this pseudo
musical staff here you can see there's
no clef therefore it's doing a musical
and UK also are holding a response
button box in their hand that has four
buttons
so this says press the purple button
then the blue one then the green one
then the red one then the blue one then
the purple one etc okay and then they
practice these passages over and over
and over and over again over the course
of three days and to ensure that they're
learning we calculate the movement time
which is the time from the first button
press to the last button press and we
see how that changes as a function of
time what you can see is that over the
three days of practice there's a
significant decrease in the time it
takes them to play one of these little
passages and that's similar to what any
of you would attest to if you play a
musical instrument
or if you play a sport or if you learn
to ride a tricycle when you were a child
okay so what we did in this experiment
was to ask what is happening in the
brain as people are learning so here we
know that behavior is changing we know
that output is changing says that what
is happening inside that allows for
to change so what we did is exactly what
I described before which is that we took
a two-minute window and extracted that
pattern of functional relationships
between brain regions and then we did it
again the next two minutes and again and
again we had 75 networks in a row for
each person that mapped out that
reconfiguration of the brain over time
and what we found is this beautiful
architecture which is that those strong
modules that I showed you before are
still present but they tend to
reconfigure at their boundaries so while
the modules themselves are relatively
strong what happens at their
intersection changes a lot so you'll
have regions of the brain that initially
are communicating with one module and
then change over time so look at this
peach one is becoming more and more
strongly connected to the yellow module
so it's switching over to its
communication pattern to the yellow one
I like to think a little bit about dance
partners and swapping dance partners in
this part of the talk because that's
that's really what these regions are
doing is that initially they're
partnering with one other region or set
of regions and then at some point in the
dance they switch over and they partner
with a different set and that allows for
a change in the pattern of communication
that is then supportive of learning new
information so what we found over the
last couple years is that brains that
are very flexible like this that's that
change these dance partners frequently
throughout time are correlated with
individual differences in in how well
that individual learns so the more
flexible the brain the better visual
motor learning is the more cognitively
flexible that person is the higher
working memory performance the person
has and better statistics in planning
and reasoning so I think it's also you
know we can we can think a little bit
about the orchestral example here too
because every now and then you have the
flute not playing with other woodwinds
but playing with the strings instead
right or every now and then you have the
trumpets playing with the bass or the
harp and that's that change in
communication can really change the
timbre of the music in the same way that
or in an analogous way to the way the
brain is changing its pattern of
communication all right so that
motivated me to ask the question
well if flexibility is related to these
wonderful things like working memory and
learning and cognitive flexibility is
there a way for us to change maybe our
lifestyle or something else to enable
better more flexible brains and so what
we did is that we studied this wonderful
data set that was actually acquired by a
fantastic professor at Stanford
University his name is Russell pulled
rack and what he did is that he actually
scanned himself twice a week for an
entire year on Tuesdays he was fasting I
think and on Thursdays he had eaten
breakfast and then he also did an entire
cognitive battery which is a set of
tests that test his cognitive function
that day and filled out a bunch of
questionnaires so not only did he give
us a year of his life doing this but
then he deposited all of that data
online for any scientist anywhere in the
world to freely use and study so big
kudos to restful track I think that's
really an amazing thing for a scientist
to do and what we found studying his
data is that on the days when he was
rested and fed he tended to have a more
positive attitude was also much more
attentive and scored more highly on the
attention tests and he also had higher
brain flexibility on those days so that
this is a correlative finding but it
suggests a causal hypothesis we could
test which is that if we alter the
amount of rest or food that someone has
in the morning that would change their
attitude and that would also change
their brain flexibility now if I tell
this story of this study to a elementary
school teacher they say oh well of
course I know that when my kids are not
rested and fed they don't do very well
but it's really nice to see some
empirical backing from neuroscience to
support that now I also want to suggest
that there are some individuals who do
not have the capacity to change their
lifestyle in this particular way and so
we still want to know whether there was
an intervention that we could come up
with that would be able to enhance
flexibility for them and so what we've
done over the last couple of years is
collaborate with andreas Meyer
Lindenberg at the Central Institute of
Mental Health and Mannheim Germany and
he has this wonderful dataset where
we're healthy individuals we're either
taking placebo or we're taking
dextromethorphan which is a drug it as
an NMDA receptor antagonist and we find
that there's actually significantly
greater flexibility when the individuals
are on txm so that suggests that there
is a pharmacological intervention that
we could offer to enhance flexibility
and I'm really interested in asking
whether we could use that prior to
rehabilitation particularly after stroke
and see if we can increase our speed
recovery particularly of motor skills
after stroke so that's the direction of
that work at the moment okay now I think
all of that is amazing and exciting and
I love this area of science but I wanted
to step back and ask some really big
questions here in the last couple
minutes and that is what is learning and
to what degree do our laboratory
experiments help us to understand the
type of learning that occurs for example
in a classroom or maybe every day at
work for you
so this type of experiment that I talked
to you about is very relevant for
understanding motor skill learning
specifically but is it relevant for
understanding learning broadly and the
kind of learning that each of you are
engaging with by coming to a community
lecture on science right all right well
to understand what is learning I'm gonna
ask to ask the broader question which is
what is knowledge what we're seeking
when we are trying to learn so we're
seeking knowledge so what is knowledge
and if we better understand what
knowledge is perhaps we can change the
kind of experiments that we do to tackle
that question more precisely alright so
I wanted to quote John Dewey here in his
1916 democracy and education where he
says knowledge is a perception of those
connections of an object which determine
its applicability in a given situation
thus we get at a new event indirectly
instead of immediately by invention
ingenuity and resourcefulness and
ideally perfect knowledge would
represent such a network of
interconnections that any past
experience would offer a point of
advantage from which to get
at the problem in a new experience all
right beautiful right so knowledge is a
network it's a network of
interconnections between concepts
between ideas between problems now if
that's the case then how do we gain this
knowledge network if we're interested in
learning how do we how do we grab that I
think we do it in two ways one is
bi-curious 'ti so again from view ii
curiosity is not an accidental isolated
possession it's a necessary consequence
of the fact that an experience is a
moving changing thing involving all
kinds of connections with other things
curiosity is but the tendency to make
those conditions perceptible so
certainly curiosity drives us to
understand the connections why why is
this related to this or what is related
to this over here how can i how can i
build how can i grow what it is that i
know but we also learn knowledge
networks by example and that's
particularly important for classroom
situations so to give you an
illustration of how we learn knowledge
networks by example I wanted to tell you
a little story which is recounted in
Robert McFarland's book called landmarks
which is a really wonderful book I
highly recommend it it's a story about
Roger Deakin who was an English writer
and documentary maker on UK waterways
specifically so the story is about a
mentee who invites Roger who was his
mentor to Cambridge University where the
mentee is currently studying and the
mentees idea is well if I invite my very
famous mentor to come and give a talk at
Cambridge everyone else at Cambridge
will think more highly of me because my
mentor gave a really great talk ok so
that was his goal and now here is his
memoir of that now-infamous day he says
I stared dedicatedly at my shoes
embarrassed that my friend was failing
to perform in front of my academic peers
it was only later that I realized it
wasn't a failure to perform but a
failure to conform Cambridge seminars
expect rigour and logic in their
presentations braced subtlety of
exposition and explanation tested proofs
of cause and
but Roger but water doesn't do rigor in
that sense and neither did Roger though
his writing was often magnificently
precise in his poetry for Roger watered
flowed fast and wildly through culture
it was protein it was slip shaped and so
that was how he followed it slipshod and
shipshape at once moving from a word
here to an idea there too fast for his
notes or his audience to keep up with
joining his watery subjects by means of
an invisible network of tunnels and
drains feel really bad for the mentee
right on the other hands I'm fascinated
by Roger
so is this person he was just an amazing
well he's an amazing scholar and he
gives lectures in this architecture
that's very similar to his subject so he
gives watery lectures lectures that sort
of meander around sometimes slow too
fast sometimes too slow you know it's
fascinating
okay so that makes me wonder our
lecturers in general perhaps are they
could they be thought of as walks
through networks and maybe it's not just
lectures maybe it's books the book that
you're currently reading is that a walk
through a network of ideas of concepts
so perhaps you're reading a linear
algebra textbook
uh-huh and the architecture of that
linear algebra textbook is highly
structured right and so that walk
through those ideas is very highly
structured I say that because we're
currently studying linear algebra
textbooks to understand their network
architecture so there's a backstory to
that or perhaps you're reading a book on
UK waterways and you may see more of
this tortuous information transmission
or perhaps you're reading a history book
now in history there's often more of
this tendril like nature right because
you're following a story through time
and it's relatively linear often or at
least that's how we can often understand
why things happened in history the way
that they happened all right so that
makes me ask the question of is there
perhaps an optimal way of walking
through a network in lectures or in
books or in papers so let's suppose that
you are currently reading a book and the
aura book chapter specifically and the
author has these 15 ideas that they hope
to present to you if it's a if it's a
fictional book you know perhaps this is
all information about the protagonist
this is information about a counterplot
this is information about the history of
the protagonist in their prior life any
of the author has to go through all of
these pieces of information but they
have to walk through it in some sort of
way that makes you on the other side
understand what that broader
architecture was and what makes this
really difficult is that language is
formally linear you only read one word
before you read the next word right and
they can only write one word before they
write the next word so everything that
you take in from a lecture or from a
book or from a paper is a linear
transmission of information but it's a
transmission of what's probably a much
higher dimensional much more complicated
object so this is the picture of what's
happening and what I'm really fascinated
by this I think is what learning really
is so here's the brain of the speaker or
a writer it has this beautiful network
structure of ideas concepts problems and
how they relate to one another the brain
of the speaker or writer Maps that into
the one dimension
of time either in writing or in audio so
that the brain of the listener or reader
on the other side can optimally
reconstruct what that beautiful higher
dimensional object was how do we do that
we do that regularly we all right we all
communicate with one another we all
speak to each other we all take very
complicated ideas and map them into one
D how do we do it
it's amazing and also how does this
person on the other side reconstruct
this complicated object from a linear
stream of information this actually is a
beautiful function of the human mind
that's important for many many behaviors
beyond listening to a lecture or reading
a book so in fact the problem of
inferring patterns of pairwise
dependencies like this between from
incoming streams of data allows us to
learn language to begin with this is how
it's thought that infants actually learn
language helps us to segment visual
images to parse tonal groupings in music
to parse spatial scenes to infer social
networks around us and to perceive
distinct concepts so it's pervasive in
all of our lives now what we've been
doing over the last couple years is
trying to understand is there a
particular kind of network architecture
that's easy to map into one dimension
and that's also easy for the other
person to reconstruct so is it perhaps
this circular one is it best if I were
to give a lecture that's circular that
means two different things to different
people is it best if I give a lecture
that has more of a torus shape or that's
very densely filled in or that has
mostly triangle so I close every gap in
knowledge I for my clothes immediately I
relate every concept to every other
concept as much as possible what is the
optimal way of presenting information
and sharing that architecture with one
another what we've found over the last
couple years is that in fact this
architecture this very highly modular
one that I showed you earlier tends to
be very easy
learned by many different people across
many different ages and so we actually
think that there might be something we
haven't I should say we haven't
comprehensively evaluated every network
architecture that's out there in the
world but our initial evidence suggests
that this modular architecture is very
very easy for humans to learn and
perhaps that would help us to present
information in classrooms to write books
to write papers and to communicate with
one another
better but I think probably one of the
most interesting features or corollaries
of this observation is that what I told
you earlier is that the human mind the
human brain looks very modular itself so
it is composed of these dense clusters
of connectivity between brain regions
and then what we're finding is that
actually the network architectures that
we are very that we find very easy to
learn have this modular structure as
well and that reminds me of this
beautiful passage from Aristotle's
metaphysics where he says mind thinks
itself because it shares the nature of
the object of thought for it becomes an
object of thought in coming into contact
with and thinking about its objects so
that mind an object of thought are the
same that raises all sorts of
interesting questions is the
architecture of an optimally learn about
network over here a topological
reflection of the optimally developed a
neural network over here or is this
correspondence in structure simply just
happenstance I think it's probably not
happenstance I think it's probably more
than that perhaps it tells us something
important about the nature of modeling
in the human brain now that's a rather
large question and I'm actually going to
leave it there I would like to
acknowledge the people who are very
important in this work particularly
these individuals here who performed a
lot of the experiments for the data that
I showed you today the team itself is
quite large we have I'm very grateful
for funding from many different
organizations that have supported the
work over the last few years I want to
thank you for listening again it was
very nice to meet you I would love to
take
yeah
yes
does this help alright so in the scale
that you used that led to flexibility in
terms of the way the brain thinks was
the scale repeated in the same way every
time or was the scale itself flexible or
varied that's a really great question
there were six different sequences so
they practice six different ones but
they were fixed they were not
probabilistic or flexible in any way one
person did six different little passages
yeah but those passages were were fixed
there was no no change so we're
certainly not teaching improvisation I
wonder if you could review that the
model that was the most connective that
you talked about a model that was easier
to understand either lecture or in a
written form whatever it would be more
easily translatable could you repeat or
kind of review that this this modular
structure that I show on the right-hand
side so what we're finding is that we
can develop a particular laboratory
experiment where we show information
that has that architecture so it's a
stream of information that's actually a
walk on that graph so if you imagine
you're a person who can walk on pages
you would stand at one of those black
nodes and that and then you would walk
anywhere that there's a blue line you
would be allowed to walk okay
but you couldn't walk in the white space
and so if you actually take a random
walk through that graph that provides
you with a passage of this concept and
this concept and this concept in this
concept right and so what we do is that
we show humans that sequence of
information that has that architecture
behind it and that's where we can tell
and then we have a little task for them
to perform that tells us how well they
learned it
hmm yeah that's a really good question
yeah
so the question is is the preference for
modular a modular network for learning
something that also holds for visual
learning because visual learning is not
linear was the statement so there's two
important pieces of information to
present that one is that you can
certainly see a sequence of images and
even though the images are
two-dimensional it's still a linear
sequence and so you can still ask
questions about what architecture those
images should come in and in that case
the modular structure is still quite
good but it does raise the broader
question of whether everything that we
learn is mapped into the one dimensional
time it you know this is an example
where I would say you have you know one
plus dimensions so you had my voice then
you had some images in the back right
and so this isn't perfectly boiled down
to a single one-dimensional problem but
that is the first approximation of the
first step is the 1d mapping books are
certainly one-dimensional unless you're
reading a textbook that has figures in
it Danny we have one over here yep good
question yes you should a relationship
between the prevalence of short paths
and IQ is there a similar relationship
when you look at creativity or you look
at motor skill abilities or other other
endpoints yeah that's a really great
question um the there we have not seen
any relationship with creativity what we
do see is that there is a pattern of
connectivity between two particular
parts of the brain that seem to be
important for creativity
so that's between what's what's called a
default mode of the brain which is the
regions of your brain that are active
when you're resting and thinking
internally and separately a set of
regions that are very active when you
have to engage with the external world
and in fact there's an interest
the connectivity between those systems
seems to be correlated with creativity
that seems to be less affected though by
the underlying structure de structural
paths I think this story is a little bit
more complicated there thank you over
here actually my question is is two
questions when you look at the
reconfiguration of circuits associated
with learning is that a random process
in which different synapses are are
tried and eventually one is decided to
be optimal and if that's the case how
does the brain decide what is the
optimal configuration what kind of
information uses to decide that a
configuration is better than the other
one so that's specifically related to
the flexible connectivity that's
correlated with learning I think yeah so
I would definitely say that we cannot
see synapses specifically at this scale
and so we can't say that these effects
are related to synaptic plasticity
because that happens at the micro scale
and we're up here at the macro scale
using magnetic resonance imaging where
each of the pixels in our image is about
one millimeter so it's not I don't think
we can make any claims about specific
synapses that are used or not used but
what we can say is that there's a change
in where the information seems to be
flowing in the brain as learning is
occurring and that could actually be
because different cognitive processes
are required early in learning versus
late in learning
so there's actually some really
beautiful historical works that suggest
that once you learn let's let's think
about this motor school learning for
example motor school learning is once
you learn the neck the mechanics of oh I
see this pseudo musical staff and that
means press this on the button box
there's a lot of very initial learning
that's just about the structure of the
experiment right and then after you've
got that pretty nailed then you go to
making the actual movements
Swifter so there are often two stages of
learning and it's called early learning
and late learning and they require
different cognitive processes so I
actually think that some of this
flexible reconfiguration that we
observed is because what's required
early in the learning of something can
be quite different than what's required
for the deeper or more automatic
learning of something was there someone
in the mezzanine who wanted to ask a
question can you speak loudly there's
definitely some beautiful work in
relating modularity to stroke and
specifically it really small arity to
the speed of recovery and the extent of
recovery following stroke so it does
seem to be supportive of the potential
for recovery I don't know about patients
with MS who have had stem cell
transplants though but certainly for
stroke the the answer is yes there is a
correlation with underlying modularity
there it's a great question you talked
about some comparisons of different
species and that our network structure
is similar but we've looked at learning
in some of these other species do they
learn in the same way that we do or
because we learn language and writing
have we shaped how our networks want to
be learned versus other species that are
learning things yeah that's a really
great question um so the sir I actually
have not studied learning in other
species yet so I don't know the answer
to a question what we are hoping to do
is to study younger children versus
older children not different species but
they do process information very
differently so at least we're going to
be able to tackle that question I think
relatively soon but going to other
species we should certainly do but we
haven't done yet has there been any
study of these phenomena under altered
states of consciousness altered states
of consciousness like sleep for example
by mind-altering drugs because we do
have data about phenomena recently which
has come out for example about how the
mind changes under the influence of say
LSD micro dosing of LSD yeah there there
are definitely some studies that have
been done to look at bringing network
architecture on and off LSD but I don't
I'm not recalling immediately whether
they specifically studied modularity but
they certainly studied changes in the
brain network organization I also don't
think that they studied I think it was
an acute dose and I don't think there
was long-term follow-up afterwards but
there is some literature out there so I
think you should probably search for it
and find it yes which is curious since
you're using the example of musical
notes and modeling how people learn and
all of that have you ever modeled
somebody who's improvising and the
different parts of the brain because of
you have muscle memory and then you have
the creative aspect of creating
something that hasn't been created
before yeah we have not studied people
who improvise but I would absolutely
love to what I have been thinking about
though is that improvisation is
basically that is a walk through a
relatively structured space too they
know which passages naturally move into
which other passages and which chords
would naturally move to which other
chords right so they are walking through
a somewhat structured space when they're
improvising I've actually also been
wondering to what degree that might
relate to how we search for him for me
is the profit process of improvisation
actually a search a search for a sound
and if so does it actually have similar
patterns to what we see in humans that
are searching for new information so
we've been studying people who are
browsing Wikipedia so these are
volunteers in our study who will browse
Wikipedia and then allow us to see what
they browsed for every day for 21 days
and they do it for 20 minutes a day and
so we can actually track how they're
walking through the space of information
and we can ask questions about to what
degree that relates to their personal
sort of level of creativity that they
propose that they suggest that they have
and also other measures of their
creative production so I think that's an
interesting direction to go we haven't
included and probably people who do
improv in that group of people but I
think that would be really interesting
because I do think that the creative
process is often very close to the
search process okay I think we have time
for about two more questions I have one
over here hi my father once shared with
me the idea that when you're teaching he
gave me a suggestion he said that people
don't often remember everything that you
said but they will remember how you felt
how they felt when you said it and the
notion was you know to engage with them
emotionally and that they'll remember
that much more powerfully I'm wondering
if you have explored the notion of how
emotion you know is emotion like a
learning accelerant if people cannot
connect to something emotionally yeah
where that what role that plays the
other thought I had if this was a room
and you were a stand-up comedian sharing
an idea that idea could be transmitted
really fast through the entire room as
the room is peeled with laughter or if
you were a musician they're connecting
it emotionally although the information
is complex it's kind of hitting them at
a different level I'm just wondering if
you've done anything in that area yeah I
think that's a really great question so
certainly in a classroom situation there
is an emotional response or any
performance there's an emotional
response to the person who's presenting
information I think it's even it's true
for books as well so my seven-year-old
the two days ago was reading the
dictionary as he does we have we have a
compact Oxford English Dictionary and I
had initially thought a compact Oxford
English Dictionary that must mean it has
fewer words than the whole thing right
but actually it's just the whole thing
but with four pages per page so it also
comes with a magnifying glass which is
why the seven-year-old is really excited
about it and every time see every time
he pulls it out it's quite old he pulls
it out he says I love that smell that
old book smell so even I think there's
an emotional response to the book even
though again that's a linear passage of
information but you might remember it
more because of the smell of the book so
yeah I think that that's absolutely true
we have not included that in our
experiments yet but I think it's an
important dimension to learning it seems
like the network structure you're you
described here is perhaps part of the
basis of language that we're receptive
to certain ways of learning language
have you studied how brains are
different and how the networks work with
different languages people who speak
Chinese or Russian or English or
multilingual people that's a really
great question we haven't yet the
individuals were studying in this the
second language we're studying right now
is mathematics so we're trying to
understand the architecture of
mathematics and come on trust that with
the architecture of English and then
understands the learn ability of those
two based on their architecture or
whether you would present them in a
different fashion so that's our that's
our initial effort but but I agree that
going to you know the to the other kinds
of languages wouldn't be a great idea as
well okay can we all give a round of
applause to Danielle for her fantastic
lecture
thank you all for coming